d'Espagne et puis la joie
argumenter
que chaque jour Qui étaient-ils parce que le
mère cancéreuse
du fruit était parce que l'aiguille
de la frontière quand ils entrent, je suis tombé à travers
la Baie s'ils entrent dans le paradis de
joie de joie
de joie quand ils entrent, ils tombent
la baie
Je dois le punir là
et aux yeux marins de mon visage
je dois le punir
parce qu'il toujours
il tombe amoureux
de qui Mauvais paiement
que tu vis toujours amoureux
quand nous venons avec moi partout
va faire quelques pas le long du mur
royal pour le mur royal pour le mur
Quand tu viens avec moi Oh, où vais-je
Prendre
Une voie
il y a une voie
J'ai voyagé et je l'ai regardée comme un guide